there is a biologically
male swimmer who's mopping up in the
female division this is a trans female
so he was born a male he was a male
swimmer just a few years ago but he's
crushing it and breaking records in all
the female swimming competitions just as
the first wave feminist feminists would
have hoped for we've got a quote here
from the new york post
leah thomas a 22 year old transgender
swimmer at the university of
pennsylvania has been shattering records
at the school before her transition she
competed for three years at penn as a
man named will thomas do we have a
picture of will oh yeah there's will
right there look at that tall guy will
look at him i don't know who that little
guy is next to him but will's a big guy
and will is now a female swimmer good
for will it is unknown when thomas
transitioned from male to female but the
swimmer competed as a man as recently as
november 2019 ncaa rules mandate at
least one year of testosterone
suppression treatment to be eligible to
compete as a woman as is always the case
in stories like this there is a lot of
controversy about the fairness of people
who are born as men competing as women
this past june the department of justice
argued that laws in arkansas and west
virginia barring athletes who were born
as men from competing in women's sports
were unconstitutional that's some fine
work there by the department of justice
the united states has a significant
interest in ensuring that all students
including students who are transgender
can participate in an educational
environment free of unlawful
discrimination the doj said in court
documents filed in a west virginia court
and can we get those before and afters
again let's just see so that's her now
right that's her now and that's her then
so there okay that's just fine now i
want to be very clear
i want to be very clear i have no
problem
with what a grown adult does with their
body and if you want to live life as the
other sex if you are trans if you want
to just dress up as a woman keep your
genitals
slice off your genitals add genitals
whatever you want to do
god bless you
i applaud you fantastic and again if you
respect me i'll respect you so i have
trans friends i know some trans people i
have no problem calling them by their uh
preferred pronouns etc but if you're
gonna be like some crazed maniac
demanding i bow to you all the time
probably not gonna do that now
do i have to add much more to this like
you guys get it this is a problem and
it's not just a problem because of the
failure of feminism so the the feminist
movement has gone from equality for all
let's have equality true equality for
women which we do have now
to now the feminist movement
is now promoting the idea that a
biologically born male should win all of
the awards in swimming as this person
transitions to a female and that they
are doing in the name of feminism and
equality it's so patently absurd that if
you wrote it in a book 20 years ago
people would have said you are crazy and
yet here we are also the fact that the
department of justice is weighing in on
this and basically forcing
west virginia schools and some other
schools to have these people compete
in the gender class that they wish as
opposed to the one that they were born
in is just absolutely bananas you'd
think that the department of justice
might have some better things to do but
here we go